Alhamdulillah.
forham.
[Silence]
Continuing in
in the chapter regarding the virtues of
knowledge and its people.
I lost my page now. Hang on a second.
[Silence]
And
here he mentions a narration on the
authority of
this is a well-known narration amongst
the scholars with respect to the virtues
of knowledge and the virtues of the
people that carry that knowledge. It's
very important to understand something.
The knowledge and its people can never
be separated.
Just the Quran and the Sunnah can
never be separated from each other.
Allah Subhanahu Waaala speaks about the
Quran and its relationship with the
people of knowledge. He says subhanahua
He says that the Quran
is clear in its entirety. Crystal clear.
clear and clarifying. Because the word
means that the verses in themselves are
clear
and
they are clear in themselves and they
are clarifying to everything else.
But where
in the pages of a book abstract? No. He
says
in the chest of those who were given
knowledge. What is knowledge? What is
meant here by the knowledge?
Meaning those people who inherited from
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam the
understanding of the Quran.
The Quran is clear and clarifying,
but
the scholars are the ones that explain
to us, teach us, illuminate what exactly
is meant by what. Because the Quran has
in it verses that are ambiguous and it
has in it verses that are explicit.
Correct?
But all of the verses of the Quran are
explicit in the chests of the people of
knowledge. To the people of knowledge,
there are no ambiguities in the Quran.
It's all clear because they understand
the Quran as Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
intended.
They understand the Quran as the prophet
Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam and his
companions understood it. Remember the
verses of poetry that we mentions in his
he says
[Silence]
Rochet
prescription.
We call it Roshet where I'm from, right?
Someone's sick, you don't give them the
keys to the pharmacy and say, "Hey, go
nuts." You know, try just go in there,
take whatever looks good to you. Try it
out. You know, try whatever fits.
Because 99 out of 100 people are not
going to walk back out of that pharmacy.
they're going to kill themselves because
the wrong medicine is poison for some.
And so in order for a person to properly
benefit from the Quran, properly benefit
from the Sunnah, which is means to
understand the Quran and Sunnah as the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
understood it because there are many
ways to understand the Quran only one
correct way. If a person
has inclinations
they can find whatever they want in the
Quran because it has ambiguous verses in
it. It's there for a reason.
[Silence]
So Allah tells us that the Quran has in
it explicit verses and it has in it
ambiguous verses.
The ambiguous verses are the verses that
those who desire misguidance,
who have in their hearts a particular
thing that they want that they desire,
they look for it where in the ambiguous
verses. So they can find justification
for anything in the Quran. Anything.
There are people that, this is a real
thing, they cite verses of the Quran as
an evidence that alcohol is halal. They
cite verses of the Quran to justify the
murder of their fellow Muslim. They cite
verses of the Quran to justify robbery
and pillaging and rape and every other
kind of atrocity you can imagine. And
this happened all the way back in the
time of the companions
with the they understood the Quran as
their inclinations
drove them as their inclinations drove
them. Why? Because they had an
understanding first then they went
looking for the evidence.
Same thing. A detective
is told there's a crime scene. He jumps
in his car and he says, "You know what?
I think it was so and so who did this. I
bet you it was this person. He did." He
hasn't even seen the crime scene yet. He
hasn't seen any evidence. He's already
got he has already predisposed
to interpreting the crime scene and its
evidence in a particular way. When he
arrives, what is he going to see? He's
only going to see what his inclinations
allow him to see. He is going to twist
and interpret everything that he sees to
fit into the narrative that he's already
decided on. This is exactly how
people have twisted and distorted the
Quran and the Sunnah of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam
things that you wouldn't imagine. People
have cited verses of the Quran as an
evidence
that
is
part of a trinity that he is the son of
Allah etc. Christians that read the
Quran they look for evidence for what?
For their trinity for the divinity of
Christ as they say and they find certain
things.
So the Quran has many interpretations
but which interpretation is correct?
Only one
only the understanding of the of the
prophet
and his companions.
[Silence]
So he mentions here a narration
on the authority of
that the messenger of Allah saiam
said and this is part of a larger
narration that many of us are
familiar with. It's a narration that
we mentions in his 40 narrations.
And Muslim Abu narrates that the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam said, "Whoever
steps on a path to seek knowledge,
Allah will use that path and make it a
path to paradise for him." Now notice
the wording of the narration.
The wording is whoever steps onto a path
to seek knowledge,
whoever steps onto that path, Allah will
make that path
a path of ease to paradise.
Before he even gets down the path, he's
already on a path of paradise.
Merely stepping onto the path of
knowledge immediately
draws a direct path to paradise for the
person on that path
because all of the knowledge of the
Quran and Sunnah is blessed.
And as soon as a person steps onto that
path immediately he has fixed himself
towards the path of paradise.
immediately before he even learns
anything. Just that intention and that
first step.
[Silence]
Allham.
just a reminder, tomorrow is Juma,
right? I didn't get my days mixed up. So
tomorrow salah is at 9:15 for Saturday
it will be at 9:00 thankfully, right?
and
salah tomorrow on Fridays, the most
beloved
time to make
and the whole week is on Friday. It's a
good time to take this opportunity to
start a good habit.